ten'll tired Coach's Corner tom
thibodeau the Timberwolves head coach
president of basketball operations and a
big night last night as they pick up
Jimmy Butler get reunited with Jimmy
Butler coach how are you this morning
I'm great thanks for having me huh well
walk me through this when you when you
first decide that ok we're going to pull
off this trade who do you call first
well from the end of the season we you
know you're preparing for the draft and
then you're thinking about you know all
the possibilities and we could tell that
by the calls we were getting for the for
the pick as we were getting closer to
the trap that many people felt it was a
very deep draft which is what we felt as
well we thought about the possibilities
of moving up there a couple of guys at
the top we really liked and we also
thought about moving back to see if we
get another veteran player to add along
with the tech and then we want to take
him in if there would be any elite
players that we can get involved with
and the hard thing was the young assets
that we felt we had that were truly
terrific players but good people good
people as well and Zach and Chris
certainly fit that and they they had a
lot of interest from other teams so once
we saw that Jimmy was available we we
pursued that and we you know we felt
very fortunate to be able to get them ok
but you call Butler do you have to call
the league who gets the college what you
first first you know like it right after
the draft and as you're getting a yeah
as you've been getting closer to the
draft all the teams are talking to each
other and you're seeing you know who who
they like on your team who you like on
their team and if there's a possibility
of making a deal or you know if they're
interested in your pick you know so I
think every team is having those
conversations and so when we we were
talking to Chicago you know we were
talking about the possibilities of
moving the pic and seeing if they would
have some players that you know they
liked on our team and they did and so we
went from there have you spoken to a
butler he's in Paris I think isn't he
we had a brief conversation last night
obviously was pretty late there and
we'll talk again today but you know I
think any time a player like that is
traded it's not an easy thing and
obviously all the things that he did for
the organization in the city and he
loved being there so but that's never
easy but he's excited about coming here
and he's looking forward to going to
work because he said the report was he
didn't want to go to Cleveland wanted to
stay in Chicago we did did he not want
to be traded at all did you did he
express those sentiments when you talked
to him no that's who Jimmy is you know
he Jimmy the you know he's a he's a very
loyal guy I think that you there very
few Pete places he would even consider
playing and uh you know but I think you
also you know you look at every
situation and he had a great run there
it was part of some great teams in
sometimes you know a team may choose to
change direction and then you know they
have to try to collect as many assets as
they can and that's what they were doing
they were in a different place and I
think for us he's exactly what we needed
we have a good young core and I like
Jimmy's age I think he's one of the
elite players in our league but it fits
our group I think Jimmy's just entering
his prime so I think this will fit for a
long time with us he said Tom Thibodeau
the Timberwolves head coach the
Continental Tire Coach's Corner I still
look at the roster last year and I
thought you guys were going to make that
leap but what you end up with 31 wins
like how does that rhyme end up with 31
wins as much talent was that you had
yeah no it's great question I think we
had a lot of leaves that we didn't close
out games well and I think that getting
hurt set us back some and then the Manya
B leaks that got hurt the last quarter
of the season so those were two key guys
particularly the shooting that they had
that they were are too much 3-point
shooters so that hurt or some but I
thought our defense it's an area we
really have to improve upon it's we were
very good offensively but we weren't
nearly as good as we have to be
defensively and
something that I think Jimmy cannot just
his mindset the way practices and of
course his ability to guard for
positions you also in and I brought this
up that you guys just didn't close out
games and sometimes you have to learn
how to close out games and I think you
guys blew more fourth-quarter leads than
anybody how do you teach that of not
losing a lead and or adding to the lead
yeah no I think you're making a great
point and I think a big part of that is
your you know veteran experience I think
of learning how to close out games so
you start off and some of that is trial
and error you have to go through it and
that's where Jimmy's been outstanding
and he had to go through the same things
there are steps you have to take as a
young player as you go through it and
Jimmy started off he you know wasn't
that player in his first couple years
and he became that player because of the
way he worked and all the things he's
added to his game since coming into the
league and that's something that I think
he can help our players with you know
when he first got to Chicago Luol Deng
really helped him and I thought that was
very beneficial to him and I think he
can do that thing that same thing for
for Carl and wig and so you know
hopefully that will happen who is the
best player in the draft in your opinion
I don't know I think we have to wait
about 15 years if you had to number one
to go to its a Nicole Ike that I think
there were a lot of really good players
that are going to have terrific careers
as I mentioned there were guys that we
were looking at the you know we thought
that they could be great could we
somehow move up and there was a lot of
talk in it you know like about you know
what you guys know how Danny Ainge is
he's he's got everything moving on on
draft night so you know work you know
under Danny what my time in Boston so
but there is you know I thought there
were a lot of possibilities in this
draft if you were to keep a pick who is
number one on your board coach who was
number one on your board you can tell me
the drafts over that Justin Patten no he
was 16th on your board
now we were you know we were thrilled uh
I'm not going to share how we had
everyone rank but we thought there were
a number we thought they were like ten
really good players in the draft how
about you put zero okay
Markel folds Alonzo ball who Jo fire can
you tell me that they were tied oh look
at you and I didn't think you're afraid
I don't think you're afraid of coach
come on yeah well we realized we didn't
have the possibility to get either one
so we moved down we'll be up there in
February I'm I'm assuming you know for
the Super Bowl so I'm assuming quartered
seats are going to be in store for me
with this one we'd love to have you yeah
yeah I'd love to have either that is
there a sweep and I can go and bring my
guys or is it just me courtside can I
sit next to the bent like and let just
let me know and so yeah we have we have
plenty of room for you you can sit on a
bench if you'd like I like that
I like can I can I go through layups
sure sure why not drop a couple plays no
no I want you it would have to keep you
in the halfcourt though yeah it'll be
like that old Iowa basketball where
there were three women at one end and
three of the other I'll just stay at the
other end there and still won't score
all right good
Congrats and good luck this upcoming
season coach thanks so much great pitar
feed their tire that's come Tom
Thibodeau but they call him coach Tibbs
Continental Tire coaches corner from Sun
to rain to snow and everything in
between Continental Tire has engineered
to tire for what you do they want you
the driver to have the traction
performance and comfort you require on
any road your travels may take you so
Continental tires engineering tires with
the extraordinary performance
reliability and putting confidence into
driving more information in the location
of a dealer near you visit Continental
Tire calm comment tire for what you do
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience